science methods provide tools to
integrate multiple data dimensions for
description of best clinical predictive
and preventive practices for reducing
racial disparities in patient Health
outcomes for intuition of patient and
family input in medical assessment and
for defining individual disease risk
mechanisms
this has given rise to significant
demand for biologists who are equipped
with data science and bioinformatics
skills for biomedical analysis that is
why to train the next generation of
data-driven biologists we have designed
the omics logic data science or
biomedical research program where you
will get an understanding of the
opportunities and limitations of machine
learning in the context of basic
pre-clinical and clinical research
in today's session we will cover data
loading and preparation data
visualization in R and python
statistical Concepts and tests
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning and finally network analysis
and deep learning
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine our
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis so how do
omisergic resources help advancementics
teaching omics logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
blooms taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is almost logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets an introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this program comes with an access to the
omic storage courses which include
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-atomics including
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using RN python as well
as cheminformatics
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
users will be given directions to access
the T by info platform for
bi-informatics processing and Analysis
of data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multiromics
platform
so first of all let us Begin by signing
up on the omic Georgette learn portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the quota looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a complete
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles which
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or kaidi or even Twitter and a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your education background and
research interest
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses Tab and finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificate stack so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the portal I'll
share the link in the chat box please
click on the link and I'll walk you
through the process behind signing up on
the portal
so here is the link
so for users who do not have an existing
account on the portal please click on
the create an account option that you
see here
here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and provide a password you
also have the option to sign up using
any of your social media accounts which
could be your Google Facebook Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
so with that I'll pause for a couple of
minutes for the participant to sign up
on the portal and once you have signed
up please put a yes in the chat box and
if you're facing any technical issues
for signing up on the portal you can
share that in the chat as well and our
team will be happy to help you
all right so I'm monitoring the chat so
once the participants have signed up
please put a yes for those of you have
already signed up you can put a done so
that we are good to go
so I'm heading for the 10 plus
participants here we have one yes
all right so in the meantime I'm going
to click on the login now option since I
already have an account and click on the
sign in option
so once you sign in you're able to view
the various courses and example projects
under the courses tab so since most of
the participants are interested in data
science
if you enter the keyword you're able to
see the various courses and example
projects that will be related to your
field of interest you can browse through
these courses and example projects at
your own pace after the session gets
over and now the most important part
when you click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email ID it will
take you to your account settings so how
do you edit the features that I
mentioned before for that click on the
icon that says profile and here you will
be able to upload your profile picture
you'll be able to enter your bio and in
my case I have linked my LinkedIn
account and my orc ID account and here
you'll be able to see the activity tab
where the community manager and the
mentor will be able to stack your
learning progress and under the courses
app it will show the courses that you
are currently completing once you have
uploaded any of the projects it will
appear under the projects Tab and once
you're enrolling for any of the programs
for example the data science program it
will at the end of the program step and
finally when you complete any of the
courses and you'll get a certificate
another certificate staff so so far if
the participants have any queries please
put them in the chat box otherwise I
would like to pass on the stage to Dr
Raga who is the research mentor and
consultant at Blind by Tech for starting
today's session
so over to you sir
thank you thank you very much let me set
up my screen sharing and we will start a
meeting
yeah can you see my screen
yes sir it is visible
okay thank you very much and uh welcome
one once again for the first session of
data science for biomedical research and
we are in this program we are focused to
help you with the methods for analysis
of Big Data data wrangling and essential
skills for uh that is required for
bioinformal patients and as well as
those who are interested in
um in in data science and data analytics
in general for non-biology related
resistors also right you can use these
methods for any data that you can apply
to but of course since this is a
bioinformatics training program we will
be focusing on using biological data
so in today's session we will go through
we'll go through an overview of what we
already have known and uh we will also
go through how to load up data in an
environment like R and Python and then
start with some basic visualization and
very importantly before diving deep
diving into the codes that is required
for visualizing the data we will
definitely discuss what are we gaining
by applying or by using different types
of visualization and what what
can be achieved by a using different
statistical analysis and how are we
going to set up our file or set up our
data
[Music]
is that the case
can you hear us yes sir you're perfectly
Audible
okay Hamida can you please check your
speaker
so how are we going to pre-process and
prepare our data and input input table
for
um helping us with the statistical
analysis and for helping us with that
visualization to proceed forward right
so let's try that so those who have
attended the orientation last week and
we will get through some of the overview
and discuss on the basics behind the
data that is being generated that helps
us with the uh with these kind of
analysis and uh relationships right we
are going to talk about big data and
yeah over the past 20 years there has
been an absolutely phenomenal growth in
the adoption of high throughput
sequencing Technologies like next
Generation sequencing in clinical
practice in clinical research in
biotechnological research in
pharmaceutical research and Etc these
Technologies produce an exponential
growth of publicly available homage data
and this trend of available data has
produced a big data problem that
precludes many biologists and clinicians
from understanding or from extracting
all the knowledge from these data
regarding the nature of for example
relationship between any molecular
drivers and this is mechanisms
relationship between clinical phenotypes
and the data and trying to understand
the relationship between malignant
processes and benign processes so to
give you another
dimension or visualization about
the generation of data at a Breakneck
speed at an unprecedented speed you can
just look at the number of full genomes
that is submitted for the SARS Kobe 2 or
kobit 19
um this is a source code to virus right
so this virus has been active for the
last three years and we already have
crossed something like
um twenty thousand twenty uh I think
it's two thousand or twenty thousand uh
yeah I think uh 20 genes per month I
think in addition I think you'll have
something close to 50 000 or 60 000 uh
whole genome sequence of star score two
available as of now so when you compare
it with the other epidemics uh that we
had encountered and we had characterized
using Next Generation sequencing method
the SARS Ebola mirrors and zika uh they
did not uh develop or they did not
generate this so much volume of data so
all this data has actually ensure
ensured that biology in current ERA has
started to acquire characteristics of
data science as we already saw billions
of data points on genes proteins and
other molecules are combined in large
piles and these data can be
systematically studied applying data
analytics and data science methods right
so why do we have to do that analyzing
this data will actually lead to more
knowledge and more understanding of
about the living organisms that include
our health and that include
biotechnology in general that can also
be applied to crops and livestocks in
extension right such an interest of huge
volume of data and because of the data
availability of the data an increase in
the availability of the associated
methodologies and all of these has
actually completely changed the approach
towards biological research from being a
hypothesis based field for a long time
into a data driven based field
okay so what are these data that is
available and what do they characterize
inside the cell these are the omics data
and these omics data includes phenomics
genomics epigenomics and transcriptomics
and all of these only they characterize
different uh molecular levels and
molecular portions and representations
of the cell and these Technologies are
high throughput Technologies like next
Generation sequencing can be used to
explore the roles relationships in the
actions of these different types and
various types of molecules that make up
the cell and that contribute to
different uh specific kind of omics data
right many of the isomics data can be
generated using what we now call as Next
Generation sequencing technology and
these data can actually show a detailed
and higher resolution information about
the genomic variance for example and
their association with the disease State
and we can also get more more detailed
information about the patterns of gene
expression patterns of isoform
expression and their relationship
between their response Gene and
molecular response are response of the
disease to treatment so that's just one
example we can apply it to various
different comparisons that we can
generate and in addition to that we can
also study the
epigenetics modifications and uh and the
copy number variation and genomic
variation modifications which are
preceding the end results of rnac
transcriptomic data analysis variants
that we can associate with different
types of
um
yeah different
different kinds of data analysis so what
is uh let's pause for a second what is
wrong with Hamida I think everybody can
hear
right can you can you type on the chat
because since she can hear she cannot
hear
sure so I'll type in please yeah please
yeah
please respond to uh his or her question
so let's move ahead so we just discussed
about various types of data that we can
actually use to study biology from a
data analytics and data science point of
view right and uh what is actually out
there is such data available yes and
these different types of homage data are
actually available at an unprecedented
level one such repository that is
maintained by the national Center for
biotechnology information is is
is the one that has for example a
collection of peer-reviewed Articles and
biological data assets and projects and
various topics we already have gotten
our familiarity with the collection of
peer reviewed articles as PubMed is one
of the most sought out and most searched
um database for understanding or for
um
for gathering information regarding
literature or any biological or any
biomedical research topic and these
database also have biological data
assets that can contain genomic
transcriptomics epigenomic metagenomics
data sets and different combinations of
these debt assets addressing different
research topics and different biological
conditions in Sample conditions can also
be
uh identified and can also be extract
right so to give you a short number
there is oh there are over 80 000
publicly available data sets in just one
part of ncbi called gene expression
Omnibus which um which contains
transcriptomics data in particular on
primary this okay and also have other
Associated data assets but what so much
of data that is available and what is
the format of this data that is
available in these public early
retrievable repositories so most of
these data are in unstructured format or
in uh in a format that is Digital Data
but these are all unstructured data in
other words they have they are
sequencing data that is the result or
that is
um
that one can access from the output of
sequencing machines and sequencing
Technologies like next Generation
sequencing methods and high throughput
sequencies so these are all Digital Data
and this Digital Data are in a fast
queue file format for example and that
has readouts for a different genomic
positions and their subsequent
different genomic positions and their
subsequent basis identified for that
particular procedure and this
unstructured data has to be converted
into structured data in other words has
to be converted into a tabular format
and depending upon what kind of data
that you start with which omits data
type that you start with you can end up
with the different types of tabular
format output that is structured data
and depending upon what kind of
structured data that you have your
Downstream analysis and your analysis
that is going to make sense out of these
structured data will completely change
so some of the starting points about
converting uh from for converting this
unstructured to structured data is
actually accessing this data and then
cleaning up some of the data and then
you start pre-processing the data or uh
running this data through analysis
platforms and Analysis sequences and
pipelines that will take this biological
Digital Data and convert into structured
Digital Data
so as I mentioned this uh this
structuring of this omics data type uh
will be different for different types of
omics data so we need to take the raw
sequencing information which is in the
strings of letter A D G and C to
generate a data set or to generate a
matrix of continuous or categorical data
that can be analyzed statistically using
different methods and various different
methods so to do that we have to
organize a sequence of analysis steps
which we call as Pipeline and these
pipelines are specific to each types of
homics data so we will discuss about
different data processing and the
procedure to generate such data assets
and and in the end result the metric The
Matrix of continuous or categorical data
that can be obtained and can be
visualized and analyzed statistically
will be discussed today
so to do this in particular you will be
able to run complex bioinformatics
Pipeline on high performing high
performance Computing uh algorithms or
Computing cloud-based servers like key
bioinfo server and using these server
will be beneficial because running these
analysis in your computer will not be
possible as it requires high performance
and higher computational power so we
will actually we have when you sign up
for this program you have access to
different
courses and lessons in omics logic
platform and these flat these different
courses and lessons will give you how
you can set up these pipeline analysis
pipeline of analysis and convert these
unstructured data to structured data so
you can follow these methods if you are
interested or you can dive straight into
the analysis of structured data for your
data science selected project and data
since we have to understand it so there
are commonly used data types to study
DNA variation like gene expression uh to
study gene expression and to study
protein abundance and to understand the
composition of microbial communities
across different sample types all of
these are different types of data and
the one format that unites these data
are the end result that is structured
data which is in the format of table or
column right tabular form and we will
start or we will learn to explore this
table and we will we will learn to find
patterns in this table and we will able
we will be we will discuss how to or
what are the different types of data
analytics methods and machine learning
methods that we can use to mine for
patterns that is available in this data
so we will see this uh this flowchart
one more time so this is an overview of
data science and biomedical research to
understand how different stages of
analysis will work together to help us
Define the hypothesis how to verify the
hypothesis right
and you would think that we will spend
lot of time in for example in the data
analysis section but most often you you
will learn that many hours and many
lines of code are actually spent in
performing exploratory data analysis and
data pre-processing and tidying up the
data why because the quality of the data
determines the quality of the analysis
methods and quality of the statistical
models that that has been generated and
based on these statistical models we can
actually infer the results and we can
actually make some predictions
directly so when you spend lot of time
in processing and pre-processing the
data to an absolute
maximum possible level and you export
the data for all possible
trends that you can consider and and
use different visualization to
understand the data Trends and data
patterns then you can build up your
hypothesis for which you can develop
models that will test the validity of
your hypothesis and prediction based on
your hypothesis
so this way I already saw but this is
one specific pipeline that you can
actually build for
um for generating
a list of variants in genomic data
analysis a typical out for output for
this genomic data analysis can look like
this where we have
um
where we have DNA positions on the rows
and we have interesting columns and and
and their numbers associated with these
interesting columns so one of the most
important Association that we would find
is a somatic score and that is
associated with different types of uh
different types of samples that we have
inputted so these somatics scores on
this tabular column can be used to
relate
um to specific DNA positions that are
right that are to be identified as that
are statistically verified to be
associated with the tumor for example uh
tumor condition or tumor characteristics
of the sample that we are actually
studying in comparison to the normal
tissue or in comparison to the pad
normal data
this will this can be approximated or
this can be related to the differential
uh variant analysis using somatic
mutations but you don't have to use
statistical methods to identify
differential variant analysis you can
use or you can apply machine learning to
characterize R2 actually uh
to identify a limited set of DNA
positions that are related to the
related to the identification of tumor
malignancy or tumor progression whatever
we start
so another form of data that we will
definitely deal with is a
transcriptomics data where we have a
protein coding regions in the genomic
DNA that contain the large stretches of
non-coding sequences called introns
right and these introns are spliced out
and because of the variant variance or
variation in the splicing for uh in the
splicing mechanism
we would actually commonly observe
electron skipping or multiple electrons
or multiple introns um ah in transcript
multiple times and Exon duplication and
this will result in variance in the
genes and those are called isoforms so
these genes that that are produced as a
result of these trans as a result of
this transcription translation into
protein can actually be
um and their abundance level can
actually be estimated using molecularly
um isolating the mRNA molecules and then
quantifying these mRNA molecules using
specific Library preparation methods and
the data analytics method on this
pipeline that we use to quantify these
mRNA transcription data or ensure they
are called rnac Data or the
transcriptomics pipeline a typical
transcriptomics pipeline will actually
allow us to map the oh let's go back it
will allow us to map the reads to the
reference genome to understand how these
genes are expressed and and what
variation in alternative splicing will
lead to transcripts that Define a
phenotype this mapping can also result
in the quantification of these reads
specific to different genes and that
directly relate to the abundance of the
gene
relate to the abundance of the gene at
different expression levels for
different uh samples that we have
so in resulting table or resulting
structured data you might obtain a table
of continuous numeric data that is
associated with the gene IDs organized
in the rows and Sample names to organize
in the columns and their intersection
will give you the expression level of
that particular Gene for that particular
stamp right this expression level will
actually for any Gene will can actually
vary for different sample conditions
which are which is what our primary aim
to study or primary aim to relate to the
transcriptomics data analysis by
comparing different sample conditions
and one other form of data another type
of data that we will definitely or we
can definitely use
um is is a metagenomics data that will
give us quantification of the microbial
population uh present in the sample this
is a special type of data and that
actually arises or that actually comes
from the same sequencing technique but
offers a completely different point of
view of the biological sample in this
case we are not looking at a sample that
contains uh in this case we are not
looking at a at an individual sample but
we are looking at a sample that can
contain millions and billions of
microorganisms represented by their
genomes that are very different from
each other so in order to quantify these
microbial population we have to take the
gene or take the portion that is common
to most of these organisms and one such
portion is a 16s ribosomal RNA Gene and
the whole of the 16s rrna Gene are some
of the variable portions of these 16s
are already G can be used to sequence
and can be used to quantify the
microbial populations of the sample that
is involved
so some of the popular uh some of the
popular pipeline that is that is able to
do this analysis involves sickness
amplicon data analysis using data 2 and
that is another method like chime can
also be used which can take this 16s
rrna amplicon data and that can convert
this data into abundance table that
looks like this which will first
characterize or which will first
tabulate the different operational
taxonomic units across samples and their
proportional abundance for each and
every cell these otus are actually
calculated from the reads that exhibit
as particular level of sequence identity
among themselves and these otus are
expected to Cluster samples that are
ideally from same species or at least
from same genus of the organisms
sometimes it might happen that depending
upon the sequence variation we might
have
we might have
otus that can span multiple species and
we might also have multiple or same
species represented in a different otu
numbers so these are all
um Associated limitations that comes
with the otu based method which is
actually taken care of in the updated
ASV based method and which can which
actually corrects for these presence of
uh sequences that are exhibited or that
are characterized at the very low level
so let's not go into that detail but
what what we want to take from here is
the structured data is of two-fold right
at the first or the primary four we have
the otu table where we have the otus and
their abundance level characteristic for
the different samples across the columns
and these otus in the next
uh in the next level of the data is
actually uh is actually The annotation
information for this otu and their
specific taxonomic ranks of taxonomic
groups by kingdom phylum class order
family genus species are actually
tabulated and we can make uh appropriate
abundance or appropriate calculation
based on which phylum of bacterial
species are are actually present in
abundant level or which family of
bacterial species are present in
abundance level and etc etc
so
yeah those types of Downstream analysis
can be performed so one of the key steps
to perform this analysis is to load up
these structured data into an
environment like r or python so r or
python can have different types of data
different classes of data types of
different types of data depending upon
what you are loading and how they are
actually stored for example all of both
are and python will actually refer to
one dimensional data in any one specific
particular type like integer type or
like
um like character type as a vector so a
two-dimensional extension of that Vector
is a matrix and multi-dimensional or
three dimensional extension of that
Vector is the array but one common thing
that you will find between Vector Matrix
and array in in both R and python are
that they are of one data type you
cannot mix and match data types in that
uh in this specific data format so if
you are going to load up the data so we
have to open up the data and do proper
pre-processing so that we are loading
only numerical data into this Vector
Matrix or array type but what we have
and what we have uh
characterized and what we have available
to us in the structured data table is a
collection of data types we have a
column that is that identifies the the
name for each and every row that is
populated as a populated as character
type and we might have some annotation
for each and every column in addition to
the in addition to the header column or
in addition to the sample sample names
like what we have in this first Row the
first row actually annotates what are
the data types of what are the tissue
types of each and every one of these
sample that is given in this specific
um example on the left so in in
essential what we have is we might have
different data types populating the
input table or input structure data that
we have that needs to be loaded and that
needs to be
stored in a specific uh
data object so this data object is
called Data frame which is essentially a
table that can store multiple data types
one column can be numeric another column
can be logical next column can be c um
structural information so all of these
are very beneficial for us because we
don't have to do pre-processing of our
data outside R and Python's environment
and which is extremely powerful in
performing all this pre-processing so we
can load up the data as we get or as we
download from these out from these
multiple different pipelines that
convert unstructured to structure data
so these structured data can straight
away be loaded into R and Python's
environment into a data data frame kind
of an object and then we can use this
data frame to substrate or convert that
into a matrix or into a vector for
necessary statistical analysis that we
have to perform so another form of data
type or one other form of object type
that we will not use a lot but it is
very important to keep our
understanding that it is possible is the
list one difference between the list and
other other data types like vector
Matrix array and data frame is that the
uniformity at least lack any kind of
uniformity and that is actually more
flexible because that can list can
actually hold or list can contain a
different number of data right and
different for example population of data
you cannot have a data frame where one
column has 50 rows and next column has
100 rows so the number of rows are the
number of observation has to be same or
equal for a difference or for a cross
sample that we are going to load it up
as a data frame and same is true for
Matrix and same is true for array and
Vector but you can have this variation
in the length of the
and data type or length of the
structured data if you are going to load
it as a list or if you are going to
populate them into a list we will use
the powerful
um advantages nature of this list when
we are going to for example collect
multiple different results from let's
say machine learning analysis and most
of the machine learning algorithm is
going to give output in the form of list
and from here we can access different
containers or different elements of this
list depending upon the necessary that
we depending upon our need to access and
plot that specific output for our
understanding of the day so I will pause
here and ask for if you have any
questions so far so if not then we will
proceed to uh uh Associated resources
and load up some of the data processing
and visualization options that is
present in there that is given as a part
of the associated resources if you have
any questions please type in the chat
box I'm actually monitoring the chat box
as I'm talking to you as I'm presenting
so let me reshare my screen
let's set up my browser
so can you see my screen can she go to
or anybody confirm what you see yes sir
yes excellent so that's what is intended
so let's come down and in this program
page if you scroll down you will see the
associated resources that we are
discussing for right and we have lot of
topics to be covered today but I want to
cover three topics like how to load the
data and how to prepare and how to
visualize some part of the data and what
are we going to use and what are the
resources that we are going to use to do
this visualization so that you can
understand or you can practice on your
own when you are going to perform this
visualization or when you are going to
go to this associative resources and we
will also go through after performing or
after visualizing a couple of
and data and then we will go back to the
go back to the uh
presentation and discuss different
statistical analysis and different tests
that we can perform and what are we
going to learn from the exploratory data
analysis that we have to perform every
time so we can start with for example
loading data into R I have already
opened this up
so I think I explained it to you in the
last section also but I will start again
so this is this is the resource that
that will actually start from absolute
basic level we for example we start from
where you will get R and how to install
R in your computer and what are we going
to do with the r code so for example in
this code this the whole lesson is
focused only on loading data into R
mainly or primarily we can start from
different path for example we can start
from a text table or text file that can
be
that can be obtained from very many
different uh pipeline vessels that you
generally associate with the structuring
of the unstructured data so this text
file will have several columns and these
columns are going to be separated by tab
or tabular
tab delimited format in other words if
you press tab from one column it's going
to jump to the next column without any
uh
without any characters in between so
these are all important characteristics
of the data and that will come in handy
when we are going to load the data into
an environment like R so in order to do
that we have to import the data into R
and we have to use that we can use the
function read.table and read dot table
takes absolutely minimum one argument
the argument is what we are going to
pass it on to this function and that is
the file location or the file name this
file name can be if given only in
isolation then is going to search at the
directory from which you have launched r
or at the directory which is set as your
current working directory you can change
this current working folder or current
working directory in ours environment
and or if you want to give the exact
location of the file which contains your
structured data then you can give the
path where the text file is located
followed by the file name text so if you
end the read dot table function with
only the file name is going to assume
some of the characteristics that is that
it has that it has default values
Associated or assumed assigned to and
then start loading the table or start
loading your file based on those
Association or based on those
assumptions but the better output is
obtained when we actually
describe the input file or describe the
file appropriately for example uh where
the necessary description are whether or
not we have a row that tells what each
and every column mentions or what each
and every column specify those are the
header rows we have to tell this
function whether we have header rows
present in our data table or not and
also we have to tell by what character
or by what delimiter the the fields or
the columns in our data table is
actually separated I already told you
that most common format that you will
gain access to from publicly available
resources or from the pipeline results
that we are going to get from Tower bio
info platform will be a tab delimited
files right the delimiter is a tab is a
tab character which can be mentioned or
which can be
represented using backslash T so when
you do this in isolation at this blocked
part is going to load the load the table
and then just print out or give us an
on-screen output and when we use this
operator which is a redirection operator
takes a result of whatever is on this
side and then puts it into the object
that is mentioned on this side right
so the object name is BF which is a
short form for data frame so read.table
function gives output in the format of a
data frame that we can conveniently load
into the object with the name data frame
BF so when you want to view what's the
what is the content of the data frame
once you have executed this specific
line then you can simply type DF and
press execute that specific code line or
you can write print DN right and some of
the other available deal limiters are
comma separated format are for example
um special special case separated format
like semicolon which is more and more
useful in the omics data type because we
might have comma in our
um
in our
data somewhere for example when you have
a gene description data and that might
have comma when you have for example a
sequence related data the header might
have come up so in that case semicolon
is used okay so dot pxc is not the only
format with uh which which can be used
to load up data you can also load data
from Excel file right and for Excel file
we have to use V Dot xlx function which
is actually defined in the library open
xlx module right if you do not have this
module installed in your computer or
installed in your R environment you have
to install this package by for example
by running install that but dot packages
option and with inside this option we
have to exactly mention the name of the
module that we are trying to load so
when you are trying to execute some of
the cores that you can get access to in
in these
in these lessons and that they are not
running properly saying that the library
is not found you have to first install
those packages so with this with the
help of this function you can actually
load information straight away from
Excel file which can be useful because
many of the supplementary information
that you can get get hands to or that
you can download from the research
publication Associated publication is in
the form of excel Pi bombing right so
this we already went through
we can either mention or specify the
type of daily meter mentioned in read
dot used in read.table function by
passing out passing as part of this
argument separator or you can actually
use
read.csv which is going to assume your
file is going to be separated by comma
but if you have any other character that
separates a column other than comma then
you have to mention that separated also
so that also we can do
and once you have loaded up you can
start you can print out these five the
contents of the object using BF or print
DF or print Open Bracket DF method or
you can actually yeah you can also check
using print command yeah you can
actually check the dimensions of your
data frame or in other words if you
execute the dimension it is going to
print out the number of rows in your
data frame and number of columns in your
data plane so this is one of the first
function that you will use our first
exploration that we will use for the
data that we have just loaded in the
environment programming environment like
R and python python has a different
function that you will that we can
discuss later or we can go through the
associated python resources to find the
appropriate functions okay so what it
does and what it gives us is when we
have this output or when we have this uh
structured data that we were to
load up we can actually open the
structured table in Excel and then take
a peek into the kind of data that we
have and then you can also know the
number of columns and rough number of
rows that we have so we can verify
whether R has loaded all of the data
completely by using Dimension options
subject the dimensions of the data
generally or this is actually done to
get a feel for the data right how many
number of samples do I have how many
genes do I have what are the number of
these do I have so to get a feel for the
data
so if you use this option of printing
out everything in the data it's going to
span a long uh it's going to cover up
all of your screen on screen display and
you have to scroll to find the first few
lines of the data frame which can
actually be addressed using the head
function which will print out first five
or six rows of your data frame right
check top rows of your data frame this
can be helpful to see what are the
what are the for example header name and
what are the first few lines of the of
your data frame in general
this we already discussed we can use
print data using this or using this why
do we have two different methods of
printing data if this is going to be
successful in printing data why do we
need print
um uh Open Bracket and here so
um if you already know a little bit of
coding you would actually have guessed
it so if you are going to use or if
you're going to print any object from
inside a loop or from inside a
conditional statement like if or do
while or those kind of condition
statement this method of printing data
just by calling the object name is not
going to work you have to explicitly
mention that you are going to print the
data inside the loop to print the data
output that is what you will do
okay so once you have gone through the
lesson like this you can actually
explore or you can actually try it out
yourself here in the practice code
section which we have given it for you
to practice what you have learned so far
for example let me do the practice first
practice so it says that in the previous
step you have learned how to read the
data here is some of the our console
which you can access as it is loaded in
the back end in our server and you can
use this console to practice your our
code that you have learned so what this
code actually does this is part of
import data code and this has given that
we can we have to substitute the paths
where the text file is located from this
specific link so you have to right click
on this link and copy link address and
then go into this location and then
select this and delete this and within
the course you have to paste the link
location so and then you can actually
read
what is actually given what is the
challenge here the challenge is to
complete the missing parts of the code
based on what you have learned so far to
successfully run the code so I if I just
run it by replacing or substituting the
path of the input file and run it it's
going to throw me an error and most of
the time this error is not going to make
any meaning just like any programming
languages error but as we have given us
given you a challenge of
completing the missing parts of the code
and missing syntaxes of the code I can
look thoroughly to which are the
portions that are missing so let's clear
my R console output like by using this
method and and if I see that the
read.table function is not completed so
let's put reader table and then if I go
here other parts are completed and we
are printing out the data
frame like this and when I run
you will actually get a feedback success
in running the code and the answer is
correct so that is what you will do and
you can also load uh do uh do this for
Excel by taking the Excel file copy link
address do the same for Excel file
here the read.xls it's actually
completed but what happens is the print
there is nothing in the print not data
so if you just run like this
it's going to say success in running the
code but answer is incorrect what does
it mean the code that you have entered
does not have any syntax error but the
intended answer for this code block is
completely different please read the
challenge and complete that so what do
we want to do important view the Excel
file so in order to make the Excel file
viewable I have to print the data print
it again so when I do that and run it
I get success in running the code and
the answer is correct so now you get the
hang of it how to use the resources
learning resources to learn the code
first and to practice the code and
complete the challenges here so we have
given some extra biological data sets to
try and some extra functions for you to
try to if you are interested you can try
but this is not going to be
this is going to be covered in upcoming
sessions also so you don't have to fret
a lot so let's go again to the lesson 2
which involves processing and
visualization again this followed
exactly the same structure where we
introduce you to different types of data
and different types of visualization
that you can perform with the data you
can use scatter plot you can use box
plot you can use categorical plot you
can use wire plot to understand
different aspects and different
um information that is present that you
can condensed the data so after going
through interaction you can actually
learn the code from the same code
breakdown format so where you are you
are going to load up the data this we
have gone through one more time and then
we start now with the pre-processing and
transformation of the data for
visualization remember we discussed the
data containing both the character
column and the necessary uh
a numerical column for performing
visualization and statistical analysis
so we have to isolate the character
columns store it in some other object
and then take only the numerical column
for uh using it for visualization so
that is what it is done here and you
will get some other code helpful uh
helpful code
and
um for example a helpful description of
what are we intending to do here for
example here we are trying to access the
um take out or remove the first row of
this data which can be removed like this
if you are familiar with r so if you are
little bit unfamiliar with r so we have
some introduction to uh R uh an
introduction to python courses in the
associated resources which you are
encouraged to try which start from
absolute Basics right even basic layer
than this that starts from how to access
different portions of the data frame and
how to set up different visualization
and Etc so when you do that then you are
pre-processing and transformation of the
data codes will become little bit more
clear and then we clean the data for any
values which can be available or which
can be present in our input data and
then we can do the transformation then
finally we can visualize it like
data we have given a plotly output of
the box plot but when you do this box
plot in RS environment the output that
you are going to get is going to be
different or it is going to be formatted
different from what you're going to see
here you will not get the
interactiveness in our Python's standard
libraries so
this is a special library that
encourages you to go through the
different portions of the data by
increasing the interactiveness of that
so again you can visualize data in
different format what are the advantages
that people definitely discuss and you
will
get practice the code or practice uh get
access to some of the challenges that
you can use to generate different types
of data like scatter plot box plot
histogram and heat map after learning
this so
um with that I'm going to stop and pause
for a couple of seconds to have to
answer if you have any questions and uh
if you do not have any questions I see a
chat
yes so yes this question which software
can we use it for plotting they are on
python environment is capable of
plotting in multiple different quality
Graphics output and plotting outputs
that you can even use for publication
that we have been using for publication
for a long time so R and python loaded
with the libraries that are specific for
plotting such as git plots 2 or in
Python's environment like c bond or
matplotlab are sufficient to plot in
whatever format that you want if you
want to improve or if you want to
increase interactiveness of the plotting
libraries in from python you can use
plotly and yeah to get output as an HTML
file
that can be loaded and that can be used
for uh that can be used for Interactive
plotting of your data okay let me
reshare my screen
for the
presentation
so if you have any questions please put
this up in the chat box
okay
and let me also know if you can see my
screen
yes
thank you very much let's quickly Breeze
through uh what are the different types
of data that we can get analysis that we
can perform for example uh we will learn
to plot a histograms Scatter Plots and
bar plots why to find relationship
between the data and to explore the
different ways to characterize these
millions of data points per sample right
so what are we going to gain by
visualizing for visualization of the
data for example one of the important
steps that you would have you would
encounter in um in data pre-processing
is log scale transformation of the data
why do we need to transform your data
into logarithmics game if you plot the
expression data for example in its raw
form the box plot is going to look like
this the boxes are actually hidden
within this one specific this small area
why because the data range is huge and
the data range is not normal most of the
statistic visualization tools and
visualization options statistical
analysis option is actually better
performed and we will give you
meaningful result if you perform those
analysis on data that is distributed
normally or that follows gaussian style
of distribution so in order to convert
your skewed data which is skewed towards
lot of values close to 0 to uh to to one
that resembles normal date high or
gaussian distribution you have to
transform that into a logarithmic scale
so we are not making any change to the
data we are just changing the scale with
which we are visualizing or we are
recording the data into a logarithmic
scale so if you do that
then you will have the box plot as
mentioned is here where you can compare
the Box distribution of uh your gene
expression values across different
samples to understand
their data Tendencies right that that is
what we will use so for example the same
kind of differentiation if you are going
to plot a histogram will actually look
like this if it is plotted on a normal
or non logarithmic scale or a raw scale
but once you transform the log transform
the scale to a logarithmic scale your
histogram is going to assemble more of a
normal scale normal distribution or
gaussian distribution so for example
we will uh we will see or we will
observe that each of the gene that is
Quantified across different sample will
contain very important information about
some function in that sample right when
we want to estimate the amount of
information that this Gene contains
across all sample we can actually look
at the histogram or we can actually take
a look at that specific
expression of one one specific gene or
couple of genes across the samples as a
part of bar plot so bar plot will give
you the expression pattern of that one
gene across different samples we can
quickly verify for example does this
Gene have differential or does this Gene
is explicit at different quantities for
two different types of sample for which
I have collected the data so far for
example this Gene uh after quantine
normalization or after normalization
option which is quantity normalization
is one form of normalization where
you would actually align these
distribution of the genes that are
expressed or that have
um expression around
what under normalization is so when you
do that transformation then you will
find that
perceived the difference between the
expression quantities or expression
quantities of this one gene across the
sample
this data into a normal scale or normal
distribution so this distribution or
this analysis of this visualization
gives us a false hope that this Gene
might be differentially expressed in
triple negative data or triple negative
samples compared to the ER positive
samples which is in which is a
comparison here but after normalization
we find out that this is going to be
this is in fact Express after comparable
range
okay yeah that is what is actually given
in uh in details here and we can also
for example uh use the different types
of representation like uh scatter plot
representation to C or to actually
verify their replicates and their
expression level and their correlation
between the data that that they are
intended to represent for example we
know that the technical replicates has
to be closely or that correlation
between the technical replicants has to
be one and correlation between the
biological replicates will be good if
they approach one right the technical
replicates are basically duplicate
measurements biological replicates or
measurement with a different sample
under the same condition so we are going
to take an average of this sample
expression levels under different under
this condition for different samples in
order to process their
expression table or in order to process
their structured data so we can compare
the expression patterns or we can
compare the data of our sample between
the biological replicates to see how
they are situated or how they are
compared how they are compared to or how
what are the what are their distribution
and whether they follow
um
good correlation uh between the
biological replicates that we are
estimating once again we will see
differences or we actually observe
differences when we do the same analysis
for raw data and for log transformed or
for normalized data
so this we actually went through this is
an R Studio screenshot output so which
you can actually get uh which you can
use for running all of your uh our codes
that that we uh give you in the r
lessons so you can if you have our
studio setup which I would strongly
suggest you to do so then you can run
all of the r cores in your computer
redemptions right or you can access the
code block that we have given that will
give you for uh plot output all
and it's your computer or you can access
the lessons from any computer that you
have
um logged into
yeah so this is available for both R and
also python so let's quickly Breeze
through some of the other forms of
visualization that we can do we can do a
bar plot again we saw that how birdplot
can be useful in uh either finding out
whether this Gene has expression level
that is different from for samples under
different conditions we can actually
sort this bar plot and find out which
specific sample has highest expression
for this specific Gene and which has
lowest expression for this specific Gene
and one of the others we already spoke
about scatter plot that will be used to
verify the likeness or verify the agree
agreement between the biological
replicates and and disagreement between
the samples that are from different data
types
uh can the r code line be shared shared
to whom
so we can see the this discussion
between or we can see the
um
correlation plot we can generate this
scatter plot between all the different
uh between all combinations of your data
for example if you have
um
four samples and we can perform this
this analysis for all possible
combinations and their quantifications
performed here
and you can see we have good agreement
between the biological duplicates and
not so good agreement between the
um different sample conditions which is
what we expect in a in any uh data
collection setup like this so again this
is an example of a box plot after
performing Quantum normalization where
we have very comparable uh data like
this
so that will conclude today's session so
uh if you have any questions please let
me know
uh we can discuss some of the questions
you can unmute yourself from tasks since
we are only very few of us here
so this data exploration reprocessing
will form the Bedrock of your data
analysis so more often than not we will
find patterns in the data we will find
what are the different sample types that
we have how they are similar how they
are different what are the two extremely
different sample types that I can use
for comparison and what are the for
example
um how can I segregate the data for for
my classification algorithm into
training and test data that can be based
on this exploratory data analysis and
again we can actually verify the
unsupervised machine learning outputs
from clustering analysis based on the
visualization that you are going to
generate from the exploratory data
analysis themselves so these are all
very very important which will be
extremely useful for us then as we go or
as we proceed or progress in this
program so if you have any questions I
will be happy to attend them and if not
I'm going to pass this on to Spurs I
believe
yes
so for the program structure and the
fees now I'd like to pass on stage to
sparsh for sharing the details so over
to you
thank you so much SRI gauri and thank
you so much Dr raghav so let me share my
screen and I'll quickly uh
walk you through the registration steps
and the tenures and the resources one
would have access to after joining the
program
so thank you srivori for sharing the
details
so could you please confirm if you can't
see my screen
yes we can see the program page
thank you so much
so uh yes this is uh the program page as
Dr ragle has already showed you uh the
program page if you scroll down you can
see the program overview uh why we have
conducted this program and why this
program is designed for whom it is
designed and what all topics will be
covering per session
so today was the first session and it
was on introduction uh related to the
program the topics which we have covered
today is production to bioinformatics
and data science data loading and
preparation data visualization in RN
python uh Etc
now the second
session it will be on October 4 and it
will be on processing High throughput
big data and the topics we'll be
covering are data complexity and need
for Preparation availability and
variability of data uh publicly
available publicly available data
repositories type of omix data genomic
data transcriptomic data like omic
studies basically then limitation of
statistic with analysis need of
interpretability and reproducibility
so in this program page you will see the
pro topics we'll be covering first
session as well as the online Associated
resources so once you will
program you will have access to this
program page and all the session
recordings per program for this
particular uh session as it was an
introductory session we will be sending
and rolling out emails for the
recordings and you can go through the
recordings and if you have further any
questions related to it you can bring me
through it now moving further
if you scroll down you can see three
different tenures one is of 45 days 60
days and 90 days now the common
resources in all these 10 years are
coding tutorials project examples coding
session session recordings online Mentor
Support Online technical support and
certificate after completion
now that what's the difference between
the three is in 45 days tenure you will
go through with an extensive training
and you will be applicable to only the
online mental support and the good
session which will be there during your
life a community session or live session
in the program in 60 days uh tenure you
have three different options three more
opportunities one is one-on-one mental
sessions then educational Cloud pipeline
access or D bioinfo server and an
opportunity to draft a research proposal
and present it to mental evaluation
purpose and the outcome of 16 days
tenure is supposed to presentation in
maybe your International Conference or a
research symposium now in 90 days 10
years you have opportunity a one-on-one
mentorship is obviously there uh then
project driven Cloud pipelines access on
T5 info server and then you have
the opportunity to work on an
independent research project and develop
your own research project and it it is
further publishable also in a good peer
review journal so these were the a few
of the resources which one would be uh
having access to if they'll enroll for
this particular program now talking
about the pricing so one could see uh
the pricing according to their location
according to their country which they
reside so for example right now I'll be
showing you the price in USD for all
those who are in U.S or related or
nearby locations so so for 45 days it's
dollar 150 or 60 days it's dollar 300
and for 90 days it's still at 450 and we
are providing right now with up to 50
scholarships
so if anyone wants a scholarship or like
are very keen to enroll in this
particular program but because of some
Financial issue or financial aid they
cannot so you can bring us uh on at
marketing.com has already shared my
email address in the chat box itself and
also the official contact number it is
active on WhatsApp you can directly ping
me on WhatsApp so that I can guide you
accordingly now I'll also share the link
to the
program page I guess it's already shared
thank you to your audience sharing once
again you can go through with the
program page once again so that uh if
you get to know about what all topics
we'll be covering and on which
particular date it is everything so this
was brief about the program's
registration part and uh thank you and I
will be like if there are any questions
related to the registration of these or
so so I'm happy to answer thank you for
watching issue Laurie
all right thank you so much so we'll
pause for a few seconds if the
participants have any more queries about
the registration process we'll be happy
to answer
[Music]
all right then so I guess the
participants have no more queries with
that I hope all of you are able to learn
something new from the today's session
and if you have any further queries
regarding the program details or the fee
structure please feel free to reach out
to sparsh using the details that I've
provided in the chat box and with that I
hope to see you all for the session two
of this program and thank you all once
again for your patience and have a great
day thank you so much